صهيب العصا ينضم الينا يطلعنا اكثر تقارير
غربيه تحدثت عن دور همم قوات فاجنر في
الوصول للسيطره كما اعلنت على على سوليدر
اطلانت على هذه صحيح جلال دور مهم لفاكنر
في حساب النوعيه على حساب الكميه نتابع
هذه التفاصيل في الخريطه تابعي ده
المشاهدين الكرام الحديث عن الحديث ذو
اهميه عاليه وانا عندما نتحدث عن سوريا
نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه التي تدور فيها
المعارك الى الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه من
اقليم دونيتك المناطق الحمراء في خريطه
اوكرانيا هي المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه مع اقتراب هذه الحرب من
انهائه شهرها الحادي عشر على التوالي هذه
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في
اوكرانيا بشكل عام ولكن المعارك الان تدور
على هذا المحور عندما نتحدث عن همم عن
سوليدار فا نحن نتحدث عن هذه النقطه هذه
المدينه الصغيره البلده الصغيره في الجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه من اقليم دونيس تبعد
حوالي
10 كم عن بخ مت تبعد 15 كلم عن بخمس وتبعد
حوالي 60 كم عن الكراماتوست لماذا نتحدث
عن هذه الارقام باخ متكراماتورس قوه الخط
الاهم بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه التي
تسيطر على اكراماتوس وتتاخذ منها عاصمه
لاقليم دونياس حيث تسيطر القوات الروسيه
على مدينه دونيتك عاصمه الاقليم منذ عام
2014 سوليدار تبلغ اهميتها بانها فيها
مناجم استخراج الملح فيها شبكه تحت الارض
هذا يعني انها قادر على احتواء اكبر قدر
ممكن من الجنود لعده كيلومترات تحت الارض
قربها من باخمت وقربها ايضا من الكرام
تورس لذلك يكون التقدم همم التقدم الروسي
من جهه السوري دار ان صح التعبير بالسيطه
او من صحه المعلومات السيطره على السودان
فهذا يعني تحديد تهديدا مهما لكما تورك
والجهه الشماليه من اقليم بنيتك واذا ما
تم هذا الامر فهذا يعني ان القوات الروسيه
قد تسي على هذه المنطقه وقد تحكم سيطرتها
على اقليم دنيت بالكامل ولكن عندما نتحدث
عن مجموعه فاجنر فنحنا نتحدث عن هذه
المجموعه هذه شركه
فاجنر هي شركه منظمه عسكريه وشبه عسكريه
يقول البعض انها تابعه يقول بعض بانها
شركه خاصه ويقول اخرون بانها تابعه بشكل
او باخر بوزاره الدفاع الروسيه او
للمخابرات الروسيه بشكل اساسي هذه
المجموعه
الاخبار الوارده من هناك او التقارير او
التحقيقات تقول بانها انشات عام 2014 وان
اول عمليه عسكريه لهذه المجموعه كانت في
اوكرانيا عندما تقدمت هذه المجموعه في
اقليم اقليم دون بس في لوغانس ودونيس
عندما حصلت الحرب في ذلك الوقت في عام
كان لها دور كبير عام 2014 في اوكرانيا
وبعد ذلك عام 2015 تدخلت المجموعه في
روسيا حيث ارسلت روسيا مجموعه من فاجنر
الى اللي توقعات الى الجانب النظام السوري
في عام 2016
تدخلت في ليبيا الى جانب اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر وفي عام 2017 تم ارسال مجموعه
من فاجنر الى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
لحمايه مناجم الماس في تلك المنطقي قال
بان مدير الشركه الذي ظهر اليوم في
سوليدار هو يفديني بريغوجين له صلات وثيقه
بالرئيس الروسي حتى اطلق عليه البعض اسم
طباخ بوتين في مقال لاستشهاده بريس بسبب
المطاعم وشركات الماكولات التي استضافت
الرئيس بلاديمير بوتن مع شخصيات اجنبيه
رفيعه المستوى في حلول الثالث من مارس من
هذا من العام الماضي بعد اسابيع قليله من
الحرب قيل بان مجموعه فاجنر نفذت عمليتي
محاوله لاغتيال الرئيس الاوكراني فولودومي
بعد اسابيع من اندلاع هذه الحرب في مارس
عام 2002 2020 هذه لمحه عن فاجنر ودورها
في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه جلال اليك
التفاصيل